another fun video this went viral from
uh my favorite site tiktok
and this is a a coming out
sort of event to a group at a school i
think a college
but i'm not sure could be a high school
i don't know how you tell the difference
these days but um anyway
let's watch the uh this is a a female
coming out and announcing that in fact
she's she's male
um this is kind of scary because i only
realized this a couple of days ago and
i've only come out to a few people
i'm a guy
[Music]
[Applause]
and i have to go home every day and be
called my dead name
and have she her pronouns used every
time i go home
and no one realizes how hurtful it is
it's like a slap in the face
and i dyed my hair last night so i could
feel more masculine
and i was afraid i was gonna get thrown
out of the house we love you theo
okay she realized
talk about a cult right
she realized a a couple of days ago that
she's a guy
and already so i'm just going based on
what she said there but
so she's been a girl um her
whole life to this point and then a
couple days ago she realized
you know what i'm a guy and already it's
hurtful if
her parents continue to see her as the
girl
that that they they birthed and have
raised
but she thinks she could go home and say
hey by the way everything you've ever
known about me is completely wrong
and you must immediately adapt to what i
am saying right now and if you don't it
is devastatingly hurtful
it wasn't yesterday but it is today
of course knowing with these kinds of
statements like no one can ever ask
really obvious questions that aren't
gotcha questions
they're not attacks and they're the kind
of questions you would ask if you really
wanted to understand what someone is
saying
and as i've said all along this stuff
that we're hearing about gender
when people come out as oh i'm a girl or
i'm a guy
i'm non-binary i'm whatever i
i can only speak for myself i actually
want to understand
what you're trying to say i really do
and so when someone is a girl
and they wake up one morning and they
they realize that they're a guy
how like describe the process
of realizing this what do you mean
exactly
and follow-up question whatever feelings
you were experiencing
that you have decided our evidence that
you're actually a guy
how do you know that those are guy
feelings given that you
haven't been one these are basic
are these basic questions really fair
questions
nobody asks them i mean i do but nobody
else seems to
and so they don't get answered
um but this is a as
this is another cul it's all part of the
you know leftism itself is one big cult
and there are kind of offshoots
from it that diverge slightly in their
emphasis
but uh this is another version of it
this is someone who's been indoctrinated
into it brainwashed into it
a young young girl and how old she is
not very old
and uh and i feel bad for them you know
the the blame that i put for all this
the gender madness i put it on the
adults who are pushing this stuff
i don't put it on the kids
you know because they've they there are
really normal sorts of emotions that you
experience as a kid
and as a person in general but speaking
about kids
there are very normal emotions there
there's there's
confusion which is really normal you
know
there's anxiety where
this kind of unsure you're not you're
unsure of yourself you're unsure of the
world you're unsure of your place in the
world
discomfort with your body all of that
is super normal especially for kids and
especially once
they have teenage years and they're
going through puberty and beyond that
and the hormones are aging and
everything else
all of that is really normal but kids
now have been given a framework for
understanding these normal feelings
and it's a tempting framework especially
for girls
which is why this this stuff is much
more common among adolescent girls and
physical
among adolescent boys but uh they've
been given a framework
and it's it's it seems very clarifying
in the moment
where they're told oh yeah you're
feeling all that way uh because you
actually you're a guy
don't worry about what that means
exactly or how that could possibly be
the case
anyone who who questions it is just a
bigot don't worry about them but it
means you're a guy and you could start a
whole new life and have a whole new
identity
you don't like your current identity you
feel a little uncomfortable with you're
feeling anxiety you're not you're not
liking
what's happening in school your peer
group you're not feeling accepted
well you can have a whole new identity
for yourself in a moment all you have to
do is just announce it just like that
it's very tempting for confused kids
and i put it on the adults it's all
their fault well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content